la région clermontoise qui se veulent
maintenant à vocation mondialistes
puisque des spécialistes de 33 pays sont
actuellement réunies et pour trois jours
à la maison des congrès afin de
confronter leurs points de vue sur
l'endométriose d'endométriose une
pathologie gynécologique très actuel et
qui entraîne notamment attention la
stérilité
mais le problème c'est de connaître ce
qu'est exactement cette maladie les
explications de françoise atex sais pas
pourquoi les femmes endométriose on sais
pas qu'est ce qui les rend stérile quand
l endométriose ou pas toujours et nos
traitements sont à définir
voilà donc la raison de ce rassemblement
de spécialistes autour de cette
pathologie dont l'apparition n'a pas
d'explication claire et pourtant les
perturbations biologique qu'elle
entraîne sont multiples perturbations
mécanique hormonales immunitaires
biochimiques mais ne permettent pas
encore d'expliquer si c'est cette
maladie qui cause d'infertilité ou si
elle est plutôt le témoin de ces
troubles venus d'ailleurs
nous on avait envie de la chirurgie très
lourde qui revêt les ovaires l'utérus
notre moment on a dit que des tanks
d'hiver se serait efficace
certaines ont été effectivement et puis
maintenant on en arrive à une position
un peu plus équilibré où l'on pense que
dans certains cas il faut choisir les
drogues dans d'autres cas la chirurgie
pour tenter de régler surtout grand
problème qui est la stérilité
il a recommencé cette maladie se
présente-t-elle si je puis dire
effectivement ça c'est là la question
importante c'est que des fois ce sont
des femmes qui viennent parce qu'elles
ont des douleurs pelviennes d'autres
fois plus souvent parce qu'elles sont
stériles puis d'autres fois parce
qu'elles n'ont rien et c'est lorsque
nous on la coelioscopie que nous
trouvons les grains d'endométriose qui
sont des petits keith de plats leçons de
son vaste ruelle puisqu'en fait il
s'agit d'un morceau de muqueuse de
l'utérus qui n'est pas à sa place mais
qui évolue comme
l'ul et la muqueuse de l'endomètre qui
croient qu'ils poussent et puis qui
saigne au moment des règles mais qui n'a
pas l'occasion de s'extérioriser puisque
c'est à l'intérieur de petites east
alors c'est l'augmentation de volume de
ces kits qui donne des douleurs et c'est
l'augmentation de volume de cyclistes
qui donne une inflammation et des
adhérents ce qui dans une grande partie
des cas sont la cause de la stérilité
est ce que c'est une maladie qui peut
être congénitales et will actuellement
beaucoup de travaux recherche d'aidés
terrain des lots de femmes qui auraient
plus facilement endométriose audience
aperçoit de façon un peu étonnante que
quand une mère a eu l'endométriose sa
fille a plus souvent endométriose ce qui
ferait la définition de population à
risque vous savez que la médecine
moderne aime beaucoup cette notion pour
pouvoir leur apporter des traitements
dès le début peut-être une surveillance
particulière et qu elle ne l est la
tranche d'âge alors la tranche d'âge
c'est que là l'un de mes trios qui
externes c'est-à-dire celles qui
intéressent les ovaires la trompe le
péritoine ses 30 ans et l'endométriose
qu'on dit interne dans la paroi de
l'utérus et 40 ans vous avez dit que
c'était la maladie de la femme moderne à
tout à fait tout à fait de la femme
moderne car il semble bien qu'elle est
plus fréquente maintenant qu'elle ne
l'était avant
et quel serait le phénomène qui se
passerait peut-être le rythme de vie
avec les stress de la fatigue les
multiples occupations et qui ont
induisent et entraîne des troubles de
l'ovulation
donc cette confrontation est importante
a clairement fermé très importante année
importante en soi parce que
on voyait de tels avis divergent qu'il
fallait rassembler les gens pour qu'ils
échangent entre leurs sentiments et
leurs idées et puis bien sûr importante
pour clermont ferrand car ça se fait
quand même au sein de l'université terre
montferrand et c'est quand même
important que des gens de 30 pays via ne
travaillait au sein de cette université
[Musique]